this week on quadriga Israel gonzo the
hour of the extremists
these rails military operation in the
Gaza Strip has surely we can come asses
ability to fight but it has also cost
the lives of many ordinary Palestinians
the UN has warned that indiscriminate
attacks may amount to war crimes Israeli
soldiers and civilians have also been
killed driving a further wedge between
the two sides as international mediation
efforts continue Israelis and
Palestinians seem further apart than
ever fertile ground for extremists on
both sides whose answer to the problems
that the Middle East is simply to reject
the other signed your host this week Ali
Aslan hello and welcome to a new edition
of quadriga while one is inclined sadly
and unfortunately one is inclined to say
here we go again 20 years more than 20
years after the Oslo agreement Israelis
and Palestinians seem to be further
apart than ever why is this conflict
seemingly so unavoidable and unsolvable
that is what I want to talk about on
today show together with these three
experts welcome to Daniel digan who is
an Israeli journalist reporting as a
brilliant correspondent for the Israeli
Broadcasting Authority the country's
leading public TV and radio station
silica temple is the editor-in-chief of
internationally politique the leading
publication of the German Council on
Foreign Relations she also has a long
experience reporting on the Middle East
and anna Eunice is a German Palestinian
PhD student at the Graduate Institute of
International and development studies in
Geneva her academic work focuses on race
and racism in particular on
anti-semitism and anti-muslim racism
welcome to you all on today show Daniel
de Gong this latest outbreak of
conflicts started seemingly with the
kidnapping and killing of three Israeli
teenagers in the West Bank and the
repercussions if you will the revenge
killing of a Palestinian teenager my
question to you is
is what's this latest outbreak of
conflict really unavoidable did perhaps
the Israelis use the pretext use the
kidnapping and killing of the three
Israeli teenagers as a pretext for the
strikes you say seemingly it's in fact
seemingly because those Rockets have
been fired into israel since 14 years 14
years i had been many times to the road
this is a town small town near the
border of Gaza most people who live
there come are refugees or the sons and
daughters of refugees who come from Arab
countries something widely not very well
known in Germany in Europe but this is a
case and they have been suffering all
along and every two months or three
months or two years or whatever it comes
again it's it's not stopping and now
it's an outbreak which is unbearable and
it can't be tolerated by Israel it's it
it is hitting also other areas not just
stir OH but in my in my view the road is
as important as Tel Aviv or Haifa or for
that matter any other center in Israel
and it's time to stop it so on a unit
it's time to stop it says Daniel Dagon
saying Israel had no choice but to react
what's your take well my take is that
not only in Germany about also the
international community and particularly
obviously Israel is forgetting the fact
that this colonization of Palestinian
land has been happening since 48 if not
even earlier if you want to be more
precise so what is actually happening in
Gaza right now is that this small strip
of land with more than one and a half 18
million people in fact living there in a
hermeneutical a sealed-off strip is
actually defending their right to
self-determination and as a couple of
Israeli journalist as well as
international reports as well as the UN
is actually set so far this is an
attempt to break the siege
that Israel imposed for more than six
years by now seven years in total six
2002-2006 so this is something that is
being forgotten as for what mr. Erdogan
said right now as for Arab Jews
basically being living on the border of
Gaza which is true which is actually
going back to the establishment of
Israel putting these Rafi's always on
the border and the conflict zone with
Palestinians miss Rockies historically
have also been the first Arabs Jews are
Jews in general who have actually not
conscripted or had rejected to join the
army and only in the recent 30 years
that has changed due to neoliberal
racist attempts of your country to
actually break as any kind of solidarity
between Arabs Jews Christians and
Muslims zakat amber let's look at this
latest outbreak we have the sad figures
delivered by the United Nations close to
700 Palestinians that's approximately
seventy-five eighty percent we have self
a civilian aside from we can argue
whether these strikes were justified or
not but are they also proportionate well
there's always the question about
proportionality in these conflicts of
course I mean this is a very difficult
situation as is all in all is metric
Warfare's this is a difficult situation
I mean the point is that Hamas has made
a deliberate strategic decision and the
decision was to arm and to import
weapons instead of any other goods that
would serve to Palestinian people in the
Gaza Strip and we should we should take
Hamas seriously as a serious actor in
this hole in this whole theater of war
as it's called making the deliberate
decision to to really start a rain of
rockets into Israel was a deliberate one
because Hamas in a zoo is in a very
precarious situation they've been in
power since 2006 actually after boosting
everything that looked like Fatah
including showing them from from
skyscrapers in Gaza and they have not
delivered to their people there is the
siege on the Palestinian people in Gaza
no doubt about it in DC
is not only very problematic it is a
humanitarian disaster both from the
Israeli and Egyptian side but also Hamas
and we have to take this into
consideration made a clear strategic
decision which was we do build tunnels
we do use the money we did get from
Qatar and also from Turkey to build
these tunnels they're very elaborately
built they must have cost a fortune
which means we made the decision to arm
instead to build what we what we have
there to build and that has to be taken
into consideration now to respond to
this and to a rain of rockets and we've
seen far more wide-ranging Rockets this
time it's very very difficult and we see
time and again we seed for the third
time that of course there's an outcry
about the humanitarian disaster that's
happening to the Palestinian civilian
population in Gaza but it is also very
difficult for state whose first
obligation is also to protect its
citizens to stop this and this is what
any kind of mediation has to take into
consideration this has to be not only a
military approach we do need a political
approach that takes the humanitarian is
social to economic situation of the
people in Gaza into consideration daniel
dragan isn't this latest outbreak of
conflict not in fact strengthening Hamas
because as you know is it a temple
obviously said they were in a somewhat
precarious situation due to the Arab
Spring and the Syrian conflict they've
sort of lost Syria's in LA they've lost
Iran as an ally the regime change in
Egypt certainly was not in their favor
you could argue they were having a
difficult time to regroup and now these
latest outbreak of the outbreak of
conflict sort of plays into their hands
doesn't it you you've talked about the
siege which is very important important
issue but let's consider the facts I've
been many times to the crossings between
Gaza and Israel every day you can see
500 600 trucks bringing food
humanitarian assistance and everything
else not not these days these days it's
just 10 or 20 trucks because of the
because the war which is taking place
but normally they get food from Israel
from the Israeli border from the Israeli
side they get medicine they get cement
also which they used in order to build
those tunnels this is the one thing on
the Gyptian side you have also a
crossing sometimes it's open sometime is
not but one thing is sure and we have
the evidence the Rockets are the
evidence arm are coming together it has
been the situation for many years under
Mubarak maybe not to a very large extent
but it has been the situation and who
has been certainly it was certainly the
situation under Morsi from the Muslim
Brotherhood he made sure that Hamas
reach arms and has this arsenal of
weapons which can hit Tel Aviv and the
world of course in Haifa and many other
cities and towns and villages in Israel
so siege is very very relative let's
take it into proportion now one of the
reasons in my opinion why Hamas started
this particular round of conflict is
that in fact the new ruler of Egypt my
country by the way I come from Cairo I
know very good the neighborhood where
[ __ ] grew up I grew up in a
neighborhood not far from there [ __ ] is
has decided not to let those arms come
to Gaza and this is a very important
point a mass is protesting it's getting
support from qatar qatar in turkey and
it it doesn't accept the fact that the
arms are not being delivered anymore
well let's give honor
a chance to respond you've heard the
argument being made over and over again
not on the show Israel is merely
defending itself it is Hamas that is
provoking by launching rockets into
Israel I said they made a strategic
decision that's a bit different but the
the argument is being made in in the
discourse of this conflict perhaps not
by you personally but this is the the
standard response on the part of Israel
is usually to say we are being we're
being attacked we have no choice what is
your take well obviously the rhetoric
that is going on for decades maybe even
since you know 48 again I'm referring to
the colonization of Palestinian land
which is actually the root cause of it
has actually been to put the blame on
Palestinians for the non stopping of the
conflict so it actually turns around a
settler colonial conflict to make those
being colonized responsible for not
submitting themselves and that actually
recently has been published by Gideon
Levy and habits as well amira hass has
said that David CEO Goldberg a professor
at UCLA on California has made exactly
the same argument that has been the
argument of feta in the 60s and 70s this
is ongoing whether that is Hamas right
now that is arming itself the PFLP or
feta it doesn't matter it is always the
Palestinians that are wrong and at fault
for Israel not having peace and for
Palestinians to not backing down and
that is the rhetoric that you both are
employing right now so you can temple
this certainly been no talk no no lack
of attempts for peace talks here we 20
years more than 20 years ago also
agreement Madrid agreement Camp David
and I agreement you names you nay
do you name it why is we've look at
countries like Rwanda were in a time
span of two months 800,000 people killed
each other and yet the country sort of
has been able to reconcile with each
other Germany and France been to two
world wars for two world wars together
now are leading allies in the European
Union why is this conflict seemingly so
unsolvable how many hours do we have
well so unfortunately only 28 minutes
remaining well even in that short of
time it's very difficult to pinpoint I
mean certainly there were huge mistakes
made by both sides of course I think
there were many opportunities missed in
many many regards it is as if whenever
there was an attempt to get down to
negotiations first of all we do have
what we call or recorded destructing
actors in this and and we do have sort
of a missing of opportunities I mean
certainly the one thing that the
Israelis never understood was how much
distrust is by building the settlements
I think that is the one single most
stupid and arrogant thing that eroded
the Israelis ever could do the one thing
that the Palestinians always missed from
my perspective is what the exception of
Salaam Fayette for whom I do have real
great admiration instead for having a
state you have to build a state you have
to have two institutions what you can't
have is as Arfa did after Oslo 11
different security services who were
really enormously corrupt and
Palestinians rightfully complained about
this I've been to Gaza many times and of
course to West Bank I was offered to see
how corrupted was and how they were
basically also blackmailing a lot of
Palestinians and taking resources away
from them this is not how you build
estate and how you build institutions
there is of course a lack of trust
between the two sides for different
narratives there is a lack of
confronting armed extremists for whom it
is all too easy to disrupt peace
negotiations there's no trust between
Mahmoud Abbas and Netanyahu
these days for good reasons I believe
that makes it all so difficult and it's
not comparable with Germany and France
after Second World War I mean after
Second World War was clear one side had
to lose and I was Germany and they had
to lose big and visible for everyone and
that was exactly the case we need faced
in near-death experience after 1945 we
had a new conflict in a new ideological
conflict arises and we had an allied
Western powers who helped us democratize
or that is absent in the Middle East and
all of that is all of that is absences
and that's why I want to ask you to this
not there's no trust here says they okay
temper and also no empathy if you will
perhaps understanding for the other
points you daniel dragan do you
understand and i want to ask the same
question to honor units do you
understand the Palestinian position you
understand their concerns I didn't I
certainly understand just to remark you
said that you mentioned the settlements
there's not a single settle in the Gaza
Israel vacated all the settlements it
ended its military presence it's ended
its civilian presence is nearly 10 years
ago so this cannot be the reason for
Gaza to attack Israel for the
Palestinians in Gaza for Hamas to attack
Israel we have tectonic changes in the
region we have Islamic the rise of
Islamic movements we had it in Egypt and
Muslim Brotherhood Hamas is part of the
Muslim Brotherhood and it changed now it
it there is a change in Egypt Egypt
doesn't accept any more but letting it
back to my original question about
empathy as I find consolation yes I do
understand their concerns but I tell
them it's time to see their realities
what is the reality the reality the
reality is that about 1 million Jewish
refugees who were persecuted for
generations in Arab countries came to
Israel to the homeland and settle down
there
in about 600 Palestinians Arabs they
didn't call themselves Palestinian back
then but in 1940 8448 the left the
region the where State of Israel was
created there was a terrible conflict
there was a war launched by Arab
countries and by the Arabs who live
there who by the way worked together
al-husseini with the Germans with the
Nazis during the Second World War and
but let's forget about it it happened
refugees from two sides the Israeli
refugees the the Arab refugees Israelis
who came from other Arab countries
settle down I myself was in a refugee
camp can I spent a few years in a
refugee camp and then we know we started
a new life we created institutions we we
did everything in order to build a
viable say and the Arabs didn't do that
and what part of the blame a big part of
the brain in my view is with the un un
created unruhe a an edgy three dedicated
solely solely for air refugees which has
practiced the assignment of perpetuating
this status of refugee and this is the
core other units this is the quarter I
think this is I mean this is really is
the rhetoric of actually using less than
a million Arab Jews to counter to
counter the argument of less than a
million Palestinian refugees and 48 is
more than cynical miss oregon really
more than cynical we have learned from
arab jewish historians and academics
that jews of european lands have always
fled since 1492 to arab lands and to
Turkey to seek refuge from European
Christian anti-semitism and they've
always thought that so what you're
talking about even in Egypt until even
into the 50s there was a Jewish minister
for economic affairs what you're talking
about in terms of being persecuted for
generations is a mere liye and
struction of your state it is not true
you are trying to underline the actual
Palestinian argument for the right of
return and the expulsion of Palestinians
in 48 and further on in fact which is
happening until now in Gaza and in the
West Bank in Lebanon and everywhere else
so as for the arguments that we've heard
before I mean from what is coming from
your side it really I mean it really
these arguments only work if the
underlying assumption is if you're
already equated that with Germany and
France that there are two countries
nobody i was are basically already the
allusion to refer to you know the first
and second world war let's say you know
i mean even the allusion to that need
the underlying assumption that
palestinians actually have an army or a
country with a viable institution so i'm
going all in all this I was driving I
was Isaac assessment para basically what
I'm trying to say is that it's not that
you know the PA is not corrupt I'm
completely going going there with you
you know nobody trusts a best anymore
which is actually the reason why in 2006
Palestinians democratically elected
Hamas whether the west or Israel likes
that doesn't matter because Palestinians
also don't like the Likud nobody asks it
we also don't like a Republican American
Congress all right we don't like that is
anybody asking it do we actually does do
Palestinians or Arabs do they I don't
know conquer Paris no they don't I mean
what is the argument he really this is
an SMA trickle war so actually putting
the blame on Palestinians to not be able
to to build a viable state well let's go
back to the actual Camp David Accords
can David actually meant that twenty
percent of Palestinian land was left
over right now Palestinians are living
in Bantu stance this is a term used from
South Africa an actual incarceration of
black South Africans these are the white
supremacist ideology all right so this
is actually what is happening right now
even if we're watching German public TV
and there's a little you know like those
geographical boundaries of the West Bank
that does not exist anymore this is a
lie this is a fabrication it does not
exist Gaza was
actually starting or the Israeli started
building a fence around Gaza in 94 in 94
this is when this government started to
build a fence around Gaza this has been
planned this is nothing that just
happened two weeks ago three weeks ago
or nothing ask for the recent events
after the the kidnapping and killing up
to 3 u's 2100 in just two weeks 2100
Palestinian homes and the West Bank have
been rated rated 700 people have been
put in indefinite detention more than
1,000 people inside of the West Bank and
Israel of Palestinian origin are now in
prison I want to hear something about
that where is actually where its
legitimacy for that this is in any kind
of international law this is forbidden
this is just forbidden as you just send
you to the history books and the yellow
star came from Arabia from the region
where Saudi Arabia is weighted today
it's situated this is for one thing so I
just send you to the history books well
history no no no I know I know I know I
don't do this then I wanted her I want
you because he books are important but
let us look for now but she said
something wrong I mean there were
programs there were persecution in Arab
countries that's effect but it was
almost to you it would has to do with
maestro it has to do because I in this
organization such actually thank you
created sound nice let's let's look
forward to this because how issues the
issues are still the same ever since we
started status of Jerusalem border
settlements refugees we can talk about
the prisoners of course for decades
absolutely in for water resource how to
move forward well the first thing of
course the immediate thing is and I'm
well I mean just to remark on that
you've asked me why it is so difficult
to make peace I mean this is the example
because I don't think that by giving
speeches with with Berkeley Berkeley
type speeches we get we don't get any
forward the first immediate task is to
stop the bloodshed that's going on right
now with Gaza and to mediate a ceasefire
there's no way that we can get into
bigger steps right now this is not
realistic it seems to me so who will be
the mediators Egypt has been trying I'm
not sure that Kat is a good mediator
qatar has been far too involved in
building Hamas it's not trusted by the
Israelis Egypt is but it's not trusted
by Hamas can the can the u.s. put
pressure on it I'm not so very sure what
I find interesting is that for the first
time and we see now the third round of
this surly Gaza conflict we don't see it
in the West Bank right now and I do
agree i think rating of helms and the
arresting of seven so many many hundreds
palestinians is illegal and there should
be freed immediately if it should at
least be part of a ceasefire agreement
now what I think has to be done there's
a really interesting paper on the table
right now which was designed by sure
Wilma files whose politically not very
strong leader of a very small party
Kadima who had lost a lot of seeds in
the last parliamentary elections who was
the joint chief of staff of the army but
the approaches and it's interesting in
the coming from the Israelis is finally
the inside that if we cannot solve
solved is in any way militarily anyway
but we have to have a political social
economic approach there has to be a fun
rebuilding there has to be a fund that
makes sure that the rebuilding is not
used as kumusta time
to build tunnels into Israeli
territories but concrete infrastructure
Hamas has not been building any
hospitals any schools any whatsoever but
they've been building 60 tunnels this
cannot go on this does not serve two
Palestinians in the Gaza Strip so only a
ceasefire where Hamas at one point to
the other can politically say we've
achieved something but you're cynical
enough because they also brought a
destruction upon Gaza themselves that
takes into consideration there has to be
rebuilding where there is a fund that
would make sure that this is the funds
are really used for rebuilding where
there is a certain disarmament in that
sense but would make sense in my view
and this is the first thing from then
from there we might take it and make
another attempt and yes of course there
has to be pressure on the Israelis to
come forward of course there has to be
pressure on stoppin on settlement etc
but the first immediate thing is to try
to get a ceasefire negotiated well as
we've seen as we've seen on this show as
well emotions run very high when we talk
about this particular conflict and it's
no different the conflict that is not
only confined to the region let's have a
quick look a Street battle about Gaza
yet it's not happening in the Middle
East but in a suburb of Paris French
police moved in when pro-palestinian
protesters defied a ban on demonstrating
amid the unrest a Jewish shop was
reportedly set on fire and anti-semitic
slogans were shouted
not for the first time criticism of
Israel is being used as a cover for
anti-jewish hatred I think that people
he understands that when you try to burn
a synagogue when you attack the police
station where you call this anti-semitic
slogans it is the values of the Republic
that are put in a question in Germany to
there have been many pro-palestinian
demonstrations in some cases anti-jewish
slogans have been shouted prompting
sharp condemnation from the German
government while honor units we've just
seen the pictures of the protests taking
place all across the world but
particularly in Europe I want to focus
on Germany because obviously Germany due
to its historic ties to the State of
Israel has a special role here the
protests we've seen the protests we've
seen taking place in German cities
sometimes the the the line between
criticism of the State of Israel and
blatant anti-semitism was crossed what's
your take first of all actually since
since there are two people having a
different opinion from mine I'd like to
respond to to what you've said before
actually Hamas came out with a ceasefire
proposal middle of July that has
completely been you know let's say
neglected or not even picked up upon by
Western politicians and the media which
actually demanded exactly what you just
said the lifting of the siege and
internationally an internationally
supervised air and sea port by zun UN
controlled borders so actually Hamas is
asking for the UN to control the borders
to huzza the increasing of the fishing
zone to 10 kilometers the lips meet with
12 on the table right now just you
that's very nice that it's two more
that's very sweet um
so you know they're much more it's
actually 10 demands that I'm the rest
I'm actually missing right now from the
top of my head as for your question well
as for for what we've just seen in
France from what I've heard from you
know comrade in Paris from the Jewish
community whatever a rabbi apparently
came out and said that the attack on the
synagogue didn't happen I'm not Sarah I
wasn't there I'm not you know I'm not
I'm not try to find about the products
that did take place let's not get in you
shot the footage you know in the details
is some people equate criticism directed
towards the State of Israel as anti anti
semitism this is there's a fine line to
be crossed you know yeah well i think
you know historically speaking what
actually anti-semitism means is that
there is a certain at Eastern European
lands which is where it comes from or
Christian European lens is that it's
actually a fantasy or investment into a
fantasy and through the figure of the
Jew where you know you make this you
know Fantas matic figure responsible for
everything even if you only have five
Jews in the country or you don't even
know you but you know ASAP could
actually said you know even if there
were no Jews you know Europeans would
have still invented anti-semitism and I
think this is exactly one of the prime
pillars of what anti sandwiches maybe
even racism in general means so actually
having so basically you don't have a
conflict and you still gas six million
people right this is what anti-semitism
means in the Middle East you actually
have a conflict and what Zionism managed
to do is to actually equate Jewishness
with the State of Israel but it always
wants Israel always once and the purple
the the supporters of the State of
Israel always want its opponents and
critics to make that very clear line and
distinction between Jewishness and
Zionism whereas even the Israeli state
doesn't do it even though even though
the Jewish Defense League in France for
instance they also don't do it so it's
really i mean it's it's a slippery true
you know i'm not saying that
anti-semitic slogans didn't happen but
we really have to look at the facts and
as well if a league i just recently said
you know the actual moment that was made
by the Israeli state to conflate these
two things you know Jewishness antha is
really state this is really this is a
fundamental problem dahlias are gone
unfortunately you live in denial you
deny the fact that Jews were persecuted
in our countries for many years for
hundreds of years you deny that the
yellow star comes from Arab lands you
did not denying that sorry sorry sorry I
didn't interrupt you I didn't interview
please let me speak you deny the fact
that the area of Jordan is also a part
of the Mandate of Palestine so the
country is much bigger than you
presented it here and the herbs control
eighty percent of Palestine actually and
not just twenty percent as you said or
as you imagine so we have here we have
to get the facts straight those protests
I heard them I live in berlin and I
heard them and in the ville him street
which is a major street in Berlin I
heard I don't want to repeat the slogans
and they heard i think what what is
really a source of concern for for
Germans for Europeans for myself too it
should be for you to but II or not you
don't seem to be concerned is the fact
that they those extremists those
activists they were mainly Arabs I think
or Muslims radical Muslim I think they
feel that the society the German society
is tolerating this this is the problem
günter grass spoke a few months ago
about the Jews and they say that Israel
is the most dangerous country in the
world something like that this enhances
anti-semitism this enhances such
protests this gives them legitimacy and
this is a problem in
this should be a source of concern for
Germany which it is may is of course
there are of course enormous emotions
involved which are which are fired up by
the conflict I I do not think that any
one of those guys who were protesting
the streets is left untouched but what
they see on TV and what they're watching
is is mainly Arab TV who were a bit less
how would I say I'm sensitive about
showing the mouse cruel pictures because
they think this is important to do to
show what's really going on now what we
see is anti-semitism in Europe the
European census racism really was not a
concept of the Muslim world in but it
seeped in Soudha Nazis also and later on
and what we see now and it's really
visible in many of the Arab media if you
if you follow this in a huge parts of
societies is a very strange phenomena
first of all design lists which are also
called the Jews you know they don't make
any distinctions here very often are
made responsible for about every evil
that's happening in every problem that's
happening in the Middle East now I'm not
saying that this was not causing
problems the occupation it is
inacceptable there no doubt about it but
the Syrian conflict a conflict in Iraq
many of the sectarian conflicts in
Lebanon don't have anything to do
whatsoever are with the
israeli-palestinian conflict I mean look
at this reward so now what what has
happened over the last decades and that
should warriors or is a general
explanation that it's the occupation as
designers to be blamed and yes there is
a paper thin line between between
emotions and rage and anger and
everything about the occupation and the
racism that is directed against the Jews
and it's no coincidence that the realize
that the valleys in Paris and the
demonstrations ended up in a synagogue
and that of course I mean we've seen the
footage there was an attempt to storm
the synagogue I've been there at the
demonstrations in Berlin and it was
amazing the kind of anger that came out
and I really I also do not want to
repeat the slogans because they are in
acceptable and I do
I think that we should accept them I
think it's absolutely it's absolutely
legitimate to express their anger but
not with slogans like that had a clearly
racist and what drives me up the wars is
we haven't seen any of this anger
expressed over the Iraq war over the
Syria war where there are two hundred
and thousand people killed we hadn't
seen this years ago and the Algerian
Civil War where there were 200,000
people killed in this in this all for
civil war the MDC Desmond Israel is
involved or when the Americans are
involved we never see this when it's
just when it's sort of an inner Arab
affair we've never seen this you know
pro pro-kurdish demonstrations and Kurds
were were persecuted awfully in turkey
until add one finally started peace
talks and other places so there is and
there is a huge element of bigotry and
and and a double standard send us on our
Eunice I mean I mean it's it's really
hard to even counter I because there are
so many things being intertwined that
have actually nothing to do with each
other so first of all I completed
distance myself from from what you
actually have said that I don't you know
take any persecution of Jewish people
seriously or anything like that that is
nonsense I think anti-semitism is a real
problem especially in Europe but what is
happening right now especially since
2000 is that more and more policy
reports academic as well as NGO work
inside of Germany and in fact inside of
Western Europe generally is pushed into
work with so called Muslims which
apparently now as we can see the
discourse evolving also materially
through funding from the from state
institutions that actually Muslims are
the new transmitters this is how they're
called in those documents as well off
anti-semitism and I think what I'm
hearing from you now is actually feeding
into that stereotype we're not talking
about the anti-semitism of user we're
not talking stereotypic we're not you
know there have been you know there were
two demonstrations we're not let me
finish first we're not talking about the
action enter some
it isn't that has not been tackled in
this country post the Holocaust or even
before whatever I mean it's not even
been a debate to my mind it's just been
a nodding of of Zionist Israeli
propaganda that's it but actually
anti-semitism was not really fully
tackled in this country so as for the
demonstrations I was at the
demonstration that was just filmed or
edited into this short little video clip
that was a demonstration of children and
women against the the war there was no
anti-semitic slogan being set other his
n which was called anti-semitic as a
reason actually is really children estoy
aqui na mara so the recent UN we provide
you the flag it's fine to drink and I am
pleased and I please tell us how it is i
do is finish this akuto what was
actually done with the footage when it
was transmitted on TV is that people
edited footage from other demonstrations
there were two were anti-semitic slogans
in berlin were actually being dropped
and we don't know these people some of
them came from the left from the right
when respect i was there are very slowly
at least finish I mean really we are
fighting a media war he even like people
the media came they spoke only to like
little children basically 15
six-year-old children the only questions
that these people were asked was about
Salafism anti-semitism and Islamism and
that was it you know and the footage
eventually I mean to actually tell us
that that saying Israel is killing
children is anti-semitic the recent UN
report that came out said that over the
past 48 hours a child every hour has
been killed through the bombardment
every hour it's real bombards UN it
bombards Ford's house for hospitals
everything I mean this is I mean we
cannot no no let me finish there's one
thing here right now actually there's a
huge anti-muslim racism luring inside of
Europe okay and those demonstrations
that we're facing right now and we have
huge problems actually understanding
who's going to demonstrate what has
being chanted sorry
is as difficult as it is to end this on
a hopeful note we only have a minute
left just one one sentence for each
despite everything that's been said
Daniel Duggan are you hopeful but i'm
very hopeful everything will be resolved
in our lifetime i am i'm very hopeful
because i think the situation Gaza where
Hamas is using the population is human
shield will end when Egypt intervenes
and I do see the hope and the vision
that Egypt will take control and manage
these situations it simple it's
difficult as it is you know with all the
slogan izing to be helpful I do see
people on both sides who put a lot of
creative thinking and energy into coming
up with new attempts and new attempts
and new attempts to solve this so on a
units one sentence I think everybody
except the you know the Western world is
on our side so I'm quite hopeful to
maybe not in the short term but in the
long run well let's find everything
that's been set on today show at least
we've ended on a hopeful known and
perhaps we can take solace and hope from
a new website that's called Jews and
Arabs refuse to hate each other that
would be a start to get things started I
want to thank my guests for a very
spirited discussion I want to thank you
out there for tuning in of course we
will continue to follow the story as it
unfolds thank you out there for tuning
in and looking forward to seeing you
again next week for a new edition of
quadriga
you